[Music]
do you feel like you're not getting any
legendary skins and overwatch lately
well you're not the only one but
blizzard recently said that it hasn't
changed the drop rates for the shooters
loop boxes I'm Matt this is a game spot
news update and make sure to hit those
like and subscribe buttons for all of
your overwatch coverage needs some
players didn't unlock any skins during
the recent year of the rooster event and
this left them wondering if drop rates
have been lowered overwatch director
Jeff Kaplan responded to this saying the
drop rates for summer games Halloween
terror winter wonderland and year of the
rooster are all the same you know that's
good to hear but it still doesn't make
me feel better about not getting Divas
skin ah the one that got away now that
the year of the rooster event has closed
I'm wondering what's next for overwatch
some of the balance changes they're
currently being tested in the PTR
they're interesting but what's got me
really excited is all the rumors
swirling around doom fist whom players
believe is an ex playable character and
I personally hope Terry Crews gets his
wish and voices him but hey while you
wait for whatever's next wanna check out
our video on the upcoming prey and how
it's like Bioshock in space